quand on parle du dénouement de la
seconde guerre mondiale beaucoup ont en
tête les images du débarquement anglo
saxons sur les plages de normandie une
opération militaire certes importante
pour vaincre l'ennemi nazi mais qui
occulte le front de l'est
particulièrement déterminant plus
généralement lorsque l'on demande aux
français quelle nation a le plus
contribué à la défaite de l'allemagne en
1945 une majorité répond que ce sont les
états unis dont les données fournies par
l'ifop
une étude est particulièrement frappante
un tableau comparatif qui recense des
enquêtes d'opinion réalisés de mai 1945
à mai 2015
on y voit clairement qu'à la sortie de
la guerre l'opinion française reconnaît
majoritairement le rôle prépondérant de
l'armée rouge
57% des sondés de l'époque font de
l'urss le pays qui a le plus contribué à
la défaite de l'allemagne les etats-unis
ne sont alors cité que par 20 % des
sondés cette étude montre que 70 ans
plus tard les courbes se sont
complètement inversé et les états unis
sont cités par une majorité pour leur
rôle prépondérant dans la victoire face
au troisième reich
alors comment expliquer un tel
changement pour annie lacroix-riz
professeur émérite d'histoire
contemporaine à paris 7
l'enseignement de l'histoire au collège
et au lycée peut expliquer ce revirement
de la perception du dénouement de la
guerre 39 45 il y a eu en 1911 janvier
1980 5 dans la revue historiens et
géographes un extraordinaire article
d'une politique américaine qui s'appelle
diana pinto elle avait analysé en
janvier 1985
la nouvelle fournée des manuels
scolaires du secondaire et elle disait
la sauce suivante elle disait c'est
parfait
les historiens sont en train de basculer
nous avons des manuels d'histoire qui
sont satisfaisants pour pour nous vous
regardez aujourd'hui d'emmanuel je
n'enseigne plus et ça fait longtemps que
j'enseigne le plus glisser mais j'ai des
petits-enfants dans les petites classes
je te constater en effet que on a une
présentation historiographique qui est
une véritable
violation de la vérité historique il
faut bien le dire si l'incontournable
bataille de stalingrad est enseignée
force est de constater que le rôle de
l'urss et peut-être sous-évalué dans les
manuels scolaires de l'hexagone et ce
alors qu'on le rappelle l'union
soviétique est le pays qui a payé le
plus lourd tribut en termes de nombre de
morts pas question d'entrer dans un
funeste concours mais les 26 millions de
soviétiques dont environ 15 millions de
soldats qui ont perdu la vie illustre
tristement l'implication de l'urss dans
le combat contre les troupes d'adolphe
hitler
si les états unis apparaissent
aujourd'hui comme les vainqueurs tout
désigné aux yeux d'une majorité de
français ils le doivent aussi à leur
influence culturelle en europe à travers
des films à gros budget hollywood
contribue à vanter les exploits des gi's
en mettant en lumière le conflit sous un
angle unique
si ces productions n'ont pas vocation à
se substituer aux récits historiques
on peut facilement supposer qu'elles ont
un impact non négligeable dans
l'imaginaire collectif des spectateurs
enfin on peut aussi expliquer cette
perception par des biais géopolitique
car la guerre froide a peut-être laissé
des traces des rivalités on peut
empêcher une transmission historique
fidèle aux événements dans leur
globalité
de nos jours encore commémoration et
célébration historique se heurte parfois
à des postures diplomatiques en 2015
pour les 70 ans de la fin de la seconde
guerre mondiale ni françois hollande ni
anglais la merkel ne s'était rendu à
moscou pour la parade militaire du 9 mai
2020 devait marquer un apaisement
puisque de nombreux chefs d'état avaient
annoncé leur présence dans la capitale
russe ces locaux vides 19 on a décidé
autrement on ne peut qu'espérer que des
cérémonies partager puisse rééquilibrer
le poids de chacun dans l'histoire avec
un grand h